is gender equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavia i mean by that
equality of outcome is undesirable what
men and women what i was gonna say let
him explain it
but
something that
he
just said
got me thinking because
as a women we're not we're not taught
like oh
go like work hard at this one thing and
like there are some women that are
taught that but most women aren't taught
go work hard at this one thing excel at
this one thing so once you reach the the
top you can be at the top and stay at
the top and go past all these people
there's more so
men that are taught that because women
children be a mother you say home mom do
this like live live your 20s and your
teens and half your 30s
uh doing you but once you get to that
point you know you're going to have to
find somebody and get married and start
having kids so it's like it's not
programmed in us to want to
be
top of a big corporation or be a ceo or
this that in the third unless someone
has said like you know if that's
something you want to do or like have an
idea like go do it it's more so
men that have been taught that and
that's why
it's so heavily ran by males
do you think it's that they're taught or
that they want to
because in my experience like i feel
like from a young age i've been told i
could do anything and i feel like
feminism doesn't really like i feel like
feminism is really big in the u.s yes i
don't think they really push women to be
mothers
i think they push women to be more
career oriented
and from what i've seen like
i just think it's more like women
who wants to work 80 hours a week my dad
did that i don't want to do that
and like he was saying men men are
more willing to do that
no
no could it be me it could not be me and
so i understand why i understand why um
there is like
more men running certain things because
they're more willing to sacrifice their
lives their body everything to be
at the top and
women will sacrifice but there comes a
point where it's just like what about me
yeah i've been sacrificing so much what
about me and so
yeah
he's making some good points here